It's very fascinating to me.
These,
um,
these sort of mindsets that you see on the left and on the right,
that there's certain subjects that you,
if you support that subject,
you are automatically thought of as a left winger.
Have you support this subject,
you're are automatically thought of as a right.
If you were on the right,
you probably think,
yeah,
in some way.
Like there's,
if someone says to me that they think that climate change is probably an
overblown thing and it's a cycle that the world has been going through forever,
I go,
Oh,
you're a winger and you'd be right.
Yeah.
Well,
almost always,
always,
always.
And if you think,
you know,
all gay people should be allowed to get married,
who cares?
Oh,
you're probably left winger.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that was probably 10 years ago and it's actually less true now.
That's one of these amazing changes.
So sometimes there can be these changes.
It's just catch us all by surprise.
And gay marriage is one of them.
I mean,
that was like,
uh,
even people on the left have misgivings about climate change.
I remember.
But gay marriage,
I'm sorry,
in the 90s,
it was still something that a lot of people on the left,
we're kind of had the mean,
let's not go that far.
Maybe we should have civil unions or you know,
uh,
now the whole of the country has flipped,
but you,
but in general,
so the f these changes can happen,
but you're right that a lot of opinions are just wealthy badges to a coalition
and they can sometimes change in,
in very strange ways.
So we've seen it in the last year or so with,
with a Donald Trump who is in many ways a pretty radical right winger,
uh,
in things like,
what do you think?
What did,
what's your opinion of Russia now for decades?
If you're on the right,
you mistrusted Russia and if you're on the left there,
you know,
they weren't so bad,
they misunderstood.
Now it's like totally flipped and opinions on whether you trust Russia,
uh,
just because of the influence of Donald Trump have shifted to the people on the
right are more sympathetic to Russia.
Something that would've been almost unthinkable a couple,
uh,
even 10 years ago.
Free Trade is another example.
It was kind of a right wing cause and then Trump managed to flip it.
So what it shows is,
I mean where I'm going with this,
and this is something that I've,
where I've changed my mind,
I used to think they were these ideologies kind of like religious catechisms
where these are the beliefs that follow from one another but a lot of is just
raw tribalism.
It just like,
you know,
in in sports the,
the,
the players,
you know,
churn through the tip,
the rosters with free agency and you know,
w w we used to be a guy who used to be a good guy.
Well now he's on the other team,
now he's a bad guy.
You know,
as Jerry Seinfeld once said,
you rooting for clothing and that kind of happens with political ideologies as
well to I think to everyone's shock.
Yeah.
That the tribalism thing is very,
very confusing to me because you,
you,
you could see it like it's such an obvious pattern.
And that when it,
when it plays out,
like,
you know,
uh,
the,
with the global warming thing,
I was having a conversation with a guy in my Jujitsu class and I'll never forget
this.
And he was like,
oh,
it's been a,
it's a cycle.
You know,
it's a cycle,
a global warming.
And then the climate change has always been a cycle.
And a,
you know,
the,
the people that say that it's not,
it's like,
Whoa,
how much should we study though I use scientists,
like,
I don't know a lot about global warming.
I don't know a lot about climate change,
but I know what I've read and it seems to me to be a very complex issue.
And I'm talking to this 25 year old guy who was in the military who's telling me
this.
I mean,
do you have an education?
And this is like,
no.
I'm like,
well,
why didn't you just automatically like decide that this is it?
We're talking about the very temperature of the planet earth.
This is complex.
And what is causing it?
Is it a carbon monoxide thing?
Is it a,
I mean,
what,
why do you just automatically subscribed to this?
And it's because that's how his tribe communicates.
This is how his tribe and that it gives people comfort to be in these weird
little groups where everybody has group thing.
Yeah.
And this is a,
uh,
I talk about this phenomenon in enlightenment now because it's a book that
argues for,
uh,
the,
the importance of reason and uh,
and how there has been progress thanks to application of reason.
And a natural pushback is,
well,
you look at things like that,
we don't seem so reasonable.
It's as a species.
How can you,
what's going on that we're getting,
we seem to be getting less reasonable.
And I think the answer is there's reason can work in for different goals.
And here I'm using the ideas of a Yale scholar named Dan Dan Daniel Kahan,
where he notes a perverse way in which there's actually is a kind of rationality
to that kind of belief.
Namely,
when you vote,
what are the chances that your vote's really gonna swing reelection pretty close
to zero.
On the other hand,
when you express an opinion in your,
your peer group,
the people you work with,
your family,
what are the chances that holding the wrong opinion will lead you to be kind of
condemned and ostracized and treated as a real weirdo?
You know,
very high.
So if you're,
if everyone thinks what opinion is going to help my esteem and the people I care
about,
they can latch on to all kinds of beliefs.
If they've become kind of identity badges for their tribe.
Uh,
this is rational in terms of the world they live in.
It's not so rational for the planet as a whole.
If people just subscribe to beliefs based on tribal loyalty instead of truth and
the challenges,
how do we align beliefs more with truth and less with tribal loyalty?
Now it's not hopeless because there are a lot of beliefs that people used to
have that are,
that have been there have been overturned.
People don't believe in Unicorns anymore or alchemy and fueled people believe in
astrology.
And,
and a lot of scientific issues are,
there's no controversy.
Do antibiotics work.
Yeah.
I mean there's no,
you don't,
it doesn't matter whether you're on the right or the left.
It's a part of the challenge is how do we get more and more of our beliefs to
be,
get,
have our social norms be such that if you believe something just because you're
on the writer of on the left,
then you're an idiot.
What you should be doing is looking at the best possible study with an open
mind.
That's what a cool person does.
And only an idiot,
just parrots though the right wing line.
That's the kind of social change we need to aim for.
Ryan.
Just almost a shaming of that kind of ignorance.
But this does the desire that people have to subscribe to a predetermined
pattern of thinking and behaving because it's,
it's comforting.
It's comforting that you know,
and then also like they know that other people on their group,
we'll also think like that.
It's like if you're in the right,
one of the things about UC,
about right-wingers is kind of hilarious.
I was watching this,
uh,
Kyle Kuklinski,
a secular talk,
a podcast where he was talking about this,
uh,
these,
Christians who are talking about Trump.
And when you are on the right,
you must have a belief in God.
You just have to,
and when they were talking about Trump,
they were saying,
we're talking about the man that existed before he accepted Jesus.
You know,
I don't have up.
And the guy was literally saying,
I don't have a past.
Okay,
how about you?
Cause I've accepted Jesus Christ into my life.
And that once you accept Jesus Christ,
like you are now a believer in Christ and you're for,
you're forgiven for all of your past sins.
And this is,
this is on the right,
there's a giant percentage of the people that are on the right that subscribed
to I a religious Christian mindset.
It is fascinating.
And especially when it comes to our current president who by any standards is
like the least Christian.
Yeah.
A leader that we've ever had asked.
He's accepted Jesus,
then he doesn't have a pass.
Well,
yeah,
but he's still,
you know,
I mean the Christian virtues include things like,
modesty,
passion for the week.
Sure.
A temperance,
chivalry gentlemen leanness and this guy is lewd and,
and vain,
glorious and arrogant and contemptuous for,
for losers.
But with shows,
again,
it kind of going back to our discussion,
it's just amazing how much of the loyalty doesn't have to do with the actual
content of the beliefs.
It's just whoever's on,
on my side.
And of course he promised a lot of perks for the,
for uh,
the,
the religious right,
like the repeal of the amendment that,
uh,
tax exempt organizations can't engage in,
in politics and in lobbying.
The so called the Johnson amendment,
which meant that if you're a church,
if you don't pay taxes,
you can't be politically active.
Well,
they didn't like that and he promised to repeal that amendment and so he got
their loyalty.
Uh,
and so it was just raw political muscle kind of overcame Christian virtue.
So bizarre.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's fascinating to watch just these patterns,
these tribal ideological patterns.
When you,
you see these groups that have this sort of one mindset in this very clear
things.
I can flip another example.
People forget this sort of taking environmentalism,
you know,
kind of quintessential,
left green because not so long ago,
it was the other way around is actually considered to be a cause of the right.
Why?
Well,
if you are,
if you're left wing activist in the 60s,
he would say,
well,
the only people concerned with the environment are rich people who like the view
from their country estates and they don't want them to be spoiled by being cut
down for apartments,
for poor people.
Uh,
or they're your duck hunters who want to be able to go and hunt ducks.
And,
and if you're really socially concerned,
you should care about Vietnam and racism and poverty.
And it's just a luxury to worry about,
you know,
trees and flowers and,
and ducks.
Now I flipped and then environmentalist and became a left wing cause.
But it these,
uh,
these connections between your coalition and your beliefs aren't set in stone.
Yeah.
Wasn't it in the beginning of the forming of this,
the political parties that it was,
the Democrats were very different and Republicans are more like Democrats?
Oh yeah.
Well starting with Abraham Lincoln,
the first republican president,
and they were the,
there,
of course they were the party against slavery.
And in fact,
even in my lifetime through the 60s,
they will,
in the south,
the Democrats were the right wing racist party.
I mean,
had George Wallace,
the governor of Alabama who said segregation now,
segregation forever.
He was a democrat.
He formed his own party and 68,
but then back in 72,
he ran for the Democratic nomination.
And the southern Democrats were they the kind of the right wingers and it was
often the northeast Republicans who are the liberals.
That's still partly true in Massachusetts.
We have a little bit of a remnant of that.
We've had some liberal Republican governors.
We have one right now.
Charlie Baker is a Republican and he's be a pretty moderate middle of the road.
Uh,
William Weld,
who was then the libertarian vice presidential candidate.
He was a Republican,
or even,
you know,
even when Mitt Romney was our governor,
he was not particularly conservative.
He's,
he was a republican.
So there's the remnant of that in Massachusetts.
They used to be a little bit of bad in New York where they were liberal
Republicans.
Uh,
but yeah,
that's a case where it's flipped a now democratic goals left of center
Republican,
Right.
Of Center.
Okay.